it's not it's not getting nice around
here first I went off on the [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass loser ass no bird no chance
ever winning troll that was in here and
now dear I throwing down on the
Portuguese wonder chicks trying to like
get married like shits going down here
on the delayed flight giving a pedigree
to being in a special my specialty of
putting the work
don't let nobody tell you what you can
or cannot be but what you can or cannot
do
[Music]
all you have to do is listen to that
voice inside and know you have greatness
within you stomp fly
[Music]
yo Amsterdam and bastard or and it
straight hurt in dudes outs picture crew
and I know a lot less English worse than
you idiot Tom Dreyfus was thinking of
Brahms thinking and sponsors just
thinking of bribes I'm thinking the
tribes or people digging me for who I am
Adam see call me who's the man watch it
at the crib talentless is not predicated
on your age especially when the game is
conducive to the use right like my 30
years of basket by 30 years of
basketball experience is not helping me
against the top recruit that's going to
Duke this year and and well I don't know
about that we haven't had our 101 oh and
we just we just have it I mean listen G
Rock I will give him the company if I
don't score give it to a give it to him
documented signed put my [ __ ]
signature put my signature on it
there's no no chance one-on-one that I
don't score it and to be very honest
with you if you keep [ __ ] talking I'm
gonna just beat you outright I know my
game limited but I'll tell you one thing
I think I'm gonna win
no that's inside you hey how are you
pleasure to see
Phoebe the name is nothing to do we get
in brain time to fly that's nothing to
do with catching place atomic difference
in these difficult times grew up a
rhymes rap music and recipient and to
make is it's a mile under cruel some
formal boxes exposes true actors not on
the same page so I write in chapters to
make you move at every [ __ ] 22-year
old in America grew up editing film for
last 10 years and have real skills we're
sorry that that happened
we're sorry that you don't have to go to
film school anymore and just start
learning and then of course by time
you're 36 we apologize the technology
came along and these talent you know
it's like it's like you want afford a
lady analogy today you want a 41 year
old basketball player like me because
I've been playing for 31 years or do you
want the kid that's going to Duke's like
talent is a veritable I know he's 17
he's been playing for less time but
that's what's happening and so so back
to where I was going over ready for God
I want to spend one or two of our film
guys and gals with these worms but
deeper than just doing my thing with
this rock
spread my wings with these ones and I
stopped it's just leaving Chicago my
PepsiCo client great day we had a lot of
fun
tense meetings important meetings with
some agency partners and with current
clients and heading to LA good day where
you focus so far early morning what's
going on snapchat just had an update you
know look into that right now
I'm gonna call the rest the CTO catch up
with him that's it there's a huge
baseball bat right there no no what you
talking about oh my god thank you
you know it's a good way to end that
little leave a comment if you want in
from 6 to 9 p.m. secret event 15 or more
2015 and 20 of you are gonna come to a
secret event with me in the Hollywood
area in LA I prepped this video the
other day a couple videos down if you
want to see it I'm more like a pink
shirt but leave a comment right now if
you want in and and left one or two plus
one so if you want to tag beyond the
person that you want to come with that's
a little secret thing but we're gonna be
on you this is how I would give its own
like this is young - listen home all
rail reliving torment what
giving home no longer day buddy wanna be
hell trouble gotta kill on Mike never
caught a body no job book I'm running
who is Tommy I know he's down in the
hole I know he's out on parole man I say
the whole world is a prison make a child
but don't let him get your soul
get it fast money is a rush getting
clean money is a dream he said getting
money here's a musta baby girl I need
you on the team we've been getting
toward ever since still a pillow just to
get the ring I'm a big Super Bowl big
it'll be really fun if this happens
small percentage chance but if it
happens I'm gonna recall this moment and
you're like that was it that's what it
happened what did you know it's amazing
to be working with progressive clients
cold cases take my living lesson
graduate of school hey guys it's Gary
I'm sitting here at the airport going
through my Instagram DM cuz that's where
it goes down no I cannot be your mentor
remain what you like you can hear me
right no I think it's good no one knows
the CTA okay good
can you hear me right now Instagram can
you hear me right now Los Angeles I will
see you I'll see you tomorrow soon as I
can get in this [ __ ] plane I will see
you and I will bring it secret thing
twenty-five people trying to get a
couple more slots right now we're
working on it some of you probably
getting hit up by seán mac or alex
DeSimone
fat carry was fun 2009 2013 there were
some there's a couple real bad shots out
there we need to dig those up and like
really do a collage of fat Gary we need
to make a fat Gary t-shirt you like that
you like that Gary t-shirt man but in
the war heart good to see you love it
love it love it alright let's do a
ridiculous contest you know what I like
the other day when we when when I made
everybody take a screenshot of the
livestream post it let's post it crap
that I ended no post it on the on their
Instagram and tag me but I should give
away something good like what about an
hour shadowing d-roc and me like in New
York thank you brother
thank you brother take care Wow 3000 on
the live stream it's nice okay who's
ruining you I'm gonna give you guys the
opportunity to hang out with me and D
rock for two hours not one they can
shadow they can shadow you
I'll find like five minutes here two
minutes their selfie and circle cookers
but I'm gonna live my normal life but
you come to New York hang out at the
vaynermedia offices for two hours and
and so that's what you can do and so
what you have to do is you have to
screen shoot this you have to screen
shoot this and you have to post it on
your Instagram right now and and you
need to tag me because that's I'm gonna
find you and use the tag functionality
so tag me in a photo like tag me in the
photo or use my handle in your copy and
say gimme Gary B give me give me the two
hours
you need to fly into New York on your
own dime or drive or take the path if
you live on East Coast or whatever but
it expires at the end of the year so if
you live somewhere and you're gonna
visit New York in the summer we can do
it then that's what we're doing let's do
it right now take a screenshot right now
of this let me take some nice glam shots
so that I can look good on your
Instagram Oh actually you know what no
if I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna clog
up your feed you need to tell people why
you follow me because I'm attractive
because I'm attractive cuz I'm friends
with Kevin Rose because I'm attractive
or maybe it's inspire or I bring value
so not only do you have to say give me
it
you have to uh you have to say you have
to say why you follow me and tell them
to follow me because that's what we're
that's what I'm getting and what you're
getting is two hours with us in the NYC
how long do I create content Allah asked
for favors Drunken it all depends on how
good it is you can put one piece of
content that's so good that everybody
wants to give you favors right away or
might take you eight years because the
collective it's really just a value
exchange that people don't understand
this is all value exchange so it's not
about how much content or how many days
it's the quality it's like how much
value did you bring you put out one
video that changes everybody's life
you could have taken one day right so
that's what's up Canada good to see you
Kyle what drives me his legacy I have
this innate feeling in my body that I'm
special that I'm all time and that I was
gifted with unbelievable talent enormous
self-confidence and humility which means
unbalanced and I'm focused and I can do
[ __ ] and so I I feel almost like guilt
of the emotional intelligence that I was
gifted and so thus legacy and guilt and
ambition drive the [ __ ] out of me I
don't care about money money's already
come money will continue to come people
understand when you level up into
passion ambition legacy passion legacy
ambition then then when you go with
those kind of tactics you start the
money always comes especially we got
talent
d-roc is here Tyler is here hey Jay Jay
deep I love for anybody to try and
expose me as a fraud [ __ ] come
see me Jay deep you real [ __ ] tough
with no icon
come see me brother come [ __ ] see me
expose me for what I am asking for [ __ ]
what you come see me
bring your tax [ __ ] receipts to show
me what you got Jay show me what you got
Jay deep and you got what you want troll
it gave me some love enjoy it drink it
[ __ ] enjoy it I love it I am
savage NIC people don't know I'm nice as
[ __ ] Tyler what percent what up want me
to come over all right people the store
want me to come over trying to be on the
livestream get over here
how you doing I'm live what's your name
can your hair right wait a minute
tell him so much okay yeah ie badd
double D yeah double D yeah go ahead
I'm just a businessman this man told me
you were gonna own a jet that man was
right mm-hmm
I'm Mary why he wanted to he wanted to
make a play I like your style good luck
and he knows how to do it
I'm the best he sure is that's T rock BM
beats mother five first of all you're
incredible second of all you got to
start a business that's practical
because raising five kids is a triple
full-time job I would say late nights
trying to build your brand trying to
sell stuff the two things that I think
is most practical is either building
your personal brand on social media or
selling stuff on let go you know
Etsy eBay those are two most practical
things that a mom of five can actually
pull off because those are the things
that you can actually do damage at 8 9
10 11 12 p.m. you know well you know
10:00 11:00 p.m.
12 a.m. 1 2 you know I love the daily
between 101 is incredible because every
time I see d-roc he's all sad that dude
came from Portugal and [ __ ] put
together the bomb piece of content I no
kidding I'm kidding
Big Ups Brazil Oh Andes and he's in the
chat he's like sorry d-roc I think you
guys have a real rivalry the Portuguese
wonder is your rival
he hasn't filmed anything nice T Rock OD
rocks throwing down Andi it's not it's
not getting nice around here first I
went off on the [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
loser ass no bird no chance ever winning
troll that was in here and now dear I
throwing down on the Portuguese wonder
chicks trying to like get married like
shits going down here on the delayed
flight Los Angeles excited for the 25
people are gonna win the contest
tomorrow secret event that you're gonna
be a part of looking forward to it
looking forward to it
he gave me a Touche he has respect for
you filming the web show the web show I
know you love it the rock stuff
everybody knows your bag ID rock you
play a good guy in on camera but we know
he's a bad guy time is the worst guy we
know I'm doing is I'm going I'm gonna
sign off right now and go into the last
post I posted for the LA secret event
and I'm gonna go pick six random winners
right now so if you haven't done that
yet go do that all rail reliving torment
ha no it's longer than anybody wanna be
he'll travel gotta kill on and Mike
never caught a body no job I'm running
who is Tommy huh no he's down in the
hole he's out on parole man I say the
whole world is a prison they could try
but don't let him get your soul getting
fast money is Russia getting clean money
is a dream she said getting money is a
monster baby girl I need you on the team
we've been getting toward ever since
still a pillow just to get the scent put
the ring on again I swear he spent put
that thing on again I thought he meant
call Kate still got me stretches take my
advice on love living lesson graduating
school they go who you touching I look
at the hog that's a blessing
I'm walking that real Road people he
taking Hill cold all night talking it
get real old never been a fool to see
real gold he'll be dropping Jews on MRI
Peter Foley drop the game son I put a
bead on I get these under someone's
control I just keep on it like you were
beginning our legs dark cloud in and out
the rain but a good time P she a pain
when the smoke clears I remain what you
think we try more like the police
planting everything so why you think we
lie more like why you think you die more
happy in his own imma [ __ ] around the
killer zone if you thinking about it get
done I'd be on that [ __ ] the brakes and
killer song I just wanna work so so sick
and it's no cure [ __ ] shoot cuz they
got no pause everybody wanna be a dope
boy I don't wanna sell dope no more just
a lotta tickets to our loser shows get
high cuz I got a lot of lows slice [ __ ]
that's the side those take the punches
in these low when I'm all sit around I'm
a go-getter
this is my soul tell what I
[Music]